c'est une des plus grandes stars
françaises qu'on a ce soir sur notre
plateau je suis très heureux que tu sois
là ça fait très longtemps que je
t'attendais tu parles tu étais venu dans
le public en plus dresse pas à mon poste
ça fait quoi ça fait bien trois ans déjà
ouais c'est regard gatti les gaps gdg
l'image s'acheter routine en un regard
des gt retrouver regarde voilà voilà
voilà voilà alors
là bas tu aimerais tu es là bas tu vois
je te vois tu vois et on a retrouvé les
images petit 10 ans et fait fuir
vu productivité on avait quand même eu
les jours a trouvé cette semaine
c'était pas ou simplement
se concentrer sur de my fab et ôté
vraiment et ainsi je te dis tu te rends
pas compte ce que tu représentes
aujourd'hui en france tu te rends compte
que tu es une légende ou pas je me
considère pas comme les jambes encore
passé c'est sûr que c'est un rêve de
gosse mais après voilà je me il en faut
plus pour être une légende quand on y
travaille mais si tu es pas ses mots que
tu dises hommes mathieu qui est
fonctionnel pour mettre à côté de lui
ses c'est non seulement la technique
c'est aussi le mental il a gagné cinq
tours contre 4 c'est le premier en gp il
a récupéré la moto d'euros si c'est ça
c'est c'est le premier français qui
gagnent passé ce premier français à
décrocher le championnat du monde en
moins de chaque pays a fait c'est juste
énorme isner
on voulait faire un petit pull violet
revoir le sacre le 24 octobre dernier et
on va en parler avec toi série qui on
est on est comme des fous
content et a vu comment c'est dangereux
il paraît que tu avais même pas il ya
entre autres le genou pendant l'hydre
une entre le chien et la piste
à
dire tu veux faire la prière donc en
tout cas tu peux pas tu peux passer
comme et ça ça non ça touche un coude et
le genou mais
de faire des plaques de fer c'est
impeccable laqué comment fonctionne un
mail serrés ces mêmes belles invité au
monde c'est vrai mais je te jure t en
plus il est beau gosse à eyl à une belle
peau
[Applaudissements]
mais j'adore comme vous ravir le d'orb à
bosser ensemble dans la botola ça c'est
ce week end va partir ensemble en année
j'adore mais vous pouvez faire un tour
de circuit derrière fabio a jugé
conforme à la baisse mais c'est très nom
et matthew pourriez le faire vous ça
serait votre rêve sein
de demain s'il accepte mais c'est
vraiment exceptionnel ça fait un peu
chier
regardez le sac regarder l'heure on
rappelle que miller fait partie des
pilotes eurent jeté sur chute deux mille
heures c'était je suis pas
d'ailleurs c'est bon délire qui a chuté
de champion aux fins d où coire chaos et
champion du monde fabio courteau c'est
difficile de se réjouir de sa chute mais
cette chute signifie que fabio au quartz
à rouleaux pilote français et champion
du monde et en virage je veux encore un
virage encore une accélération fabio
valfère famille on le ferait
façon le champagne le champagne mérité
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait on va te faire être chaud
j'prefere axium en fait là s'est lâché
une phrase à l'égard
sur la tête de ma mère tu m'aimes est ce
tu mets un homme là d'ici là mais lille
uc et qu en une sombre affaire fais moi
plaisir bon là c'est là
tu trouve quelqu'un tu me lavande au
regard de la moi à côté je vais la voir
elle avoir les boules ou
alors sa bio faut savoir un truc qui est
incroyable c'est que t'as pas le permis
moto non mais non à l'oreille parce que
sur le droit incroyable aurait pas de
permis moto non non c'est facile moto
mais qu elle connaît comment tu t'es tu
t'es show fille comme ça
c'est un jour même pas j'ai pas envie de
le passé on a envie de me le faire
passer ouais mais j'aime pas roulé sur
sur la route il ya pour moi y'a trop de
danger
parce que mes parents voulaient pas que
je me suis posée quant à l'âge de mon
fils quasiment je me suis plaint quand
tu regardes ça et tu te dis mais c'est
pas possible c'est tellement dangereux
c'est une phrase qu'on sera là
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez une question de madame
et il ajoutera je voyage et la question
je me suis demandé comment ses parents
avaient accepté que tu puisses faire des
sports pour un sport comme sadamoto en
fait en gros ils t'ont pas laisser faire
de la moto sur la route non c'est pas
j'ai commencé j'avais 4 ans donc j'étais
tout petit mais après j'ai conscient du
danger qui en moto et sur la route c'est
totalement différent sur les circuits on
sait qu'à et normand de sécurité bien
sûr on sait que chantôme on peut se
faire vraiment mal mais après c'est
totalement différent et on sait que sur
la route tu peux avoir mon univers sons
voilà tout dépend des autres et sur la
piste mais c'est toi qui qui contrôle la
tuer avait deux ans et ça c'est ça
les a bossé
cd colère
mais quand on est comme ça franchement
norvège n'abandonnera
jamais l'autre ses crocs bar du coin est
content parce que je connais pas ce que
je rencontre pour la première fois par
mr un aussi grand champion
que moi
ça va
encore arriver là cinq
champions du monde de 2,2
par une balle dans les couilles vous
risquez
qu'est-ce que fabio ce que tu connais le
jeu le paddle le tennis ou le tenais tu
joues un peu cheap heures va faire
équipe ensemble non on joue contre c'est
mieux
[Applaudissements]
alors si tu veux voir j'ai envie de me
voilà de me frotter au champion pour moi
fabio je vous dis c'est je pense qu'il
fait partie des trois plus grands
champions avant c'est vraiment d'autres
mais je le pense vraiment je pense qu'on
le pense tous ici tu te rends pas compte
quand on allait contre sauver c'est un
truc de fou d'hériter d'une humilité
d'une sympathie c'est ça qui fait
plaisir aussi c'est vraiment se dit un
aussi grand champion comme ça ou être
être aussi humble jeux devraient en
prendre de la graine
j'allais le dire vraiment mais vous
allez
les bleus sont précis
allez on vous entre ici et après c'est
interdit les marques à la télé je vous
signalais
tu vois une marque à part quand tu vas
d'avoir une charrette
et bah pas l'offrir à brigitte macron
connard
c'est entrer dans la campagne et je vous
jure mais c'est chez non et non